good morning
i had a very productive meeting today
with president biden in the white house
um
we have met several times
in the last couple of weeks
and
we have been
meeting at the g20 summit in rome and at
glasgow cop26
there we've launched together several
initiatives
on the topics of climate change for
example or trade or other geopolitical
issues
therefore today we were focusing mainly
on questions of pressing international
topics
first of all of course we've been
discussing the pandemic
and
that despite the progress in vaccination
in the united states and the european
union we have to be very vigilant that
this does not turn into a pandemic of
the unvaccinated and we have to do our
utmost that the vaccination rates are
increasing
we are also aware and determined to make
sure
that
we keep our goal in
mind that we want to vaccinate 70
percent of the global population by next
year so there's still a lot of effort to
do
we were then
focusing on
the situation on the eu belarus border
this is not a bilateral issue of poland
latvia lithuania and belarus
this is a challenge to the whole of the
european union
and this is not a migration crisis
this is the attempt of an authoritarian
regime to try to destabilize its
democratic neighbors
this will not succeed we know the
patterns
we're used to that by
seeing how there was the attempt to
influence our democratic elections
we see the cyber attacks we see the
misinformation now we have this hybrid
attack
uh by instrumentalizing migrants
at the eu belarus border
and we have to protect our democracies
from this kind of cynical
geopolitical power play
this is what i discussed with president
biden
at the white house meeting
this then led
to the question of ukraine
we agree that we fully support
the territorial integrity
of ukraine and we also fully support
ukraine
uh in its attempt to modernize
and transform the economy and to build
up resilience
also on the chosen path
and we have then discussed the situation
on the island of ireland
it is very important
that the agreement found in the protocol
and the withdrawal agreement
are in place because they are
the possibility to keep peace and
stability on the island of ireland
so we are willing as a european union to
show the utmost flexibility and we have
shown utmost flexibility within the
protocol but it is important to stick to
what we have agreed and signed together
to work with that
and finally
we've been discussing infrastructure
it is the initiative built back better
world
and the european global gateway that are
reinforcing each other
we
know that we build on the same
principles
and now we are looking into
having to identifying together the most
promising projects where we can invest
in in our common initiatives
so that was
a brief summary
from poland and i would like to ask you
about the situation of the eastern order
so what is the president's assessment in
the situation what is your current
assessment of this situation did the
president offer and helping cooperation
with dealing with this crisis yeah
we absolutely share the assessment that
this is a hybrid attack
of an authoritarian regime to try to
destabilize
democratic neighbors and this will not
succeed we will protect our democracies
we agreed that we coordinate our
outreach
to
the countries of origin
so that they take care of their citizens
not to fall into the trap of the
lukashenko regime
and we agreed that we will look into the
possibility of sanctioning
those airlines who facilitate
human trafficking towards minsk and then
the eu belarus border
and finally
and we we discussed that
we
agreed on working on that and finally it
is important
that the united nations agencies
have access
in belarus to the migrants in that very
very difficult situation that these
innocent people are in
we will widen our sanctions against
belarus
so very rapidly at the beginning of next
week
there will be a widening of the
sanctions against belarus as far as i'm
informed uh the united states have
prepared sanctions that will be in
effect at the beginning of december
and these uh the european sanctions will
not only be against
personalities but also against entities
so
it is important that the lukashenko
regime understands that their behavior
comes with of christ do you think that
russia plays a role in the migration
crisis
and um
so i think um
the
president biden and
i we share
the assessment
that it is important for peace and
stability on the island of ireland to
keep the withdrawal agreement
and to stick to the protocol
this protocol has managed to square the
difficult circle
that brexit caused
and now northern ireland has access to
both markets that has access to the
single market
the british single market as well
as
the european single market
therefore um the situation
is a positive one and we want to do
everything to cut red tape to be as
flexible as possible within the protocol
i'm not sure whether you understand
anything
so
because we see the noise that is here
that i think
we i thank you for your patience and for
the attention thank you so much